let's talk about Vice President Mike
Pence major question in the context of
the Trump Russia investigation what did
Mike Pence know when did he know it if
Trump goes down should pence go down
with him and I will remind you that
former FBI director James Comey this is
a key fact for what I'm about to tell
you James Comey was fired on May 9th
seems like a it's stunning that it's
been made June July August it's been
almost four months so much has happened
so much has happened since then but May
9th is the day that James Comey was
fired as FBI director there is a new
blockbuster story from the New York
Times which puts Mike Pence squarely in
the Oval Office on May 8th the day
before James Comey was fired
participating in a review of a letter
that Donald Trump and advisor Steven
Miller put together explaining why James
Comey was about to be fired
Donald Trump said on 8th I'm firing
Comey here's a letter I drafted about
why now why is Mike Pence's presence at
that meeting so relevant Mike Pence
previously said very clearly very
unequivocally with absolutely no doubt
that when Comey was fired it was because
of the recommendation that Donald Trump
received from Deputy Attorney General
Rod Rosenstein okay here is a quote from
Mike Pence two reporters on may 10th the
day after the firing let me be very
clear that the president's decision to
accept the recommendation of the Deputy
Attorney General and the Attorney
General to remove director Comey as the
head of the FBI was based solely and
exclusively on his commitment to the
best interest of the American people and
to ensuring that the FBI has the trust
and confidence of the people in this
nation we of course eventually learned
the real reasons for the firing Trump
wanted to do it to deflate the Russia
investigation but now knowing that Mike
Pence was in the Oval Office on may 8th
when Donald Trump came to them and said
hey I'm firing Comey here's the letter
the letter explains the reasons this
means that on May 10th when Mike Pence
claimed
Trump fired Comey on the recommendation
of the deputy AG pence knew that it was
a lie before we knew this there was
deniability right maybe on May 10th Mike
Pence believed that the firing on the
day before was because of rod Rosen
Stein's recommendation we now know pence
was in the Oval Office and he read
Trump's letter on May 8th so he knew
that he was lying with his explanation
on May 10th this is of course not Mike
Pence's only lie he claimed in a TV
interview that he didn't know about
Michael Flynn's foreign work several
people have since come forward and said
oh no Mike Pence knew all about it but
of course we can't really know all of
the things that Mike Pence knew and when
he knew them and when he lied because
for a while he was using a private email
account with America Online I mean it is
one of the few connections that we have
between Mike Pence and the Russia
scandal and even even so I mean the
connection has to do with maybe like
obstruction of justice or the cover-up
not with the initial crime and of course
pence joined the Trump campaign so late
in the game as well do you think there
will be enough to really implicate him
in all of this I don't know I genuinely
don't know it and my concern is more
that if if Trump ultimately falls and
Pence becomes the president it's
actually not that great for anybody
particularly the 300 plus million people
who live in the United States and many
people around the world so I think it's
important to anytime we have information
about Mike Pence's potential involvement
this puts him squarely in the middle of
the insane firing of James Comey
motivated by the Russia investigation so
at least what we know now is Pence's
hands aren't clean whether this will be
enough to legally implicate him at some
future point I have no idea it seems a
little bit surprising because pence
doesn't seem like someone who would lie
oh I got that impression on religious
conservative question I don't think you
would do that listen Indiana is not
sending us their best some people from
Indiana I know I'm sure are good people
I've met them but Indiana is just not
sending us our best folks that I can
assure you the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad